bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat la jeunesse de ce pays
attend elle a besoin de nous c'est en
ces termes que michel sapin s'est
exprimé hier devant les sénateurs il a
d'ailleurs exhorté les sénateurs de tous
bords à voter le projet de loi portant
création d emplois d'avenir texte dont
l'examen a donc débuté hier au sénat je
vous rappelle que ce projet de loi qui
est une promesse de campagne de françois
hollande est bien prévoit la création de
150 mille contrats aidés pour les jeunes
peu ou pas qualifiés jeunes de moins de
25 de moins de 25 ans qui viennent dans
une ayral des zones défavorisées alors
les entreprises qui embaucheront ces
jeunes bénéficieront d'une aide
financière de l'état en contrepartie
elles devront obligatoirement proposer
une formation assez jeune je vous
propose donc tout de suite de revoir la
discussion de l'article 1er bonne
matinée à tous nous reprenons la suite
de la discussion du projet de loi adopté
par l'assemblée nationale après
engagement de la procédure accélérée
portant création d emplois d'avenir
nous sommes parvenus à l'article 1er
j'ai sur l'article premier neuf demandes
parole monsieur courteau merci madame
heures résidence
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
j'ai souhaité intervenir effectivement
sur l'article 1 car il contient le coeur
du dispositif proposé aux jeunes sans
emploi ni qualification condamné à une
marginalité sociale certaine si nous
n'agissons pas je ferais remarquer que
le taux de pauvreté des jeunes de 20 à
30 ans a doublé depuis 1970 et le
chômage de masse qui frappe en priorité
les jeunes depuis 30 ans est
véritablement un désastre générationnel
je vais aussi évoqué la dimension du
pouvoir d'achat prise en compte par ce
projet de loi puisque l'ensemble des
emplois qui seront créés vont
redistribuer du pouvoir d'achat et donc
participer la dynamique de la sphère
économique
cela dit
si toute la jeunesse connaît
l'allongement de cet embouteillage au
démarrage de la vie professionnelle
certains avec la crise n'ont même plus
la chasse de pouvoir la démarrer il
était donc essentiel que ces emplois 10
emplois d'avenir s'adresse à celles et
ceux qui n'atteignent même pas une
existence statistique on en qualifiés ou
peu qualifiés qui sont de plus en plus
nombreux à ne même plus faire la
démarche de rentrer et de se faire
recenser dans les dispositifs existants
seulement la moitié des 470 mille jeunes
sans qualification ni emploi sont
inscrits à pôle emploi les autres comme
cela était déjà dix ont sorti des écrans
radars de la société l'emploi d'avenir
est aussi une chance un tremplin pour
remonter dans l'ascenseur social en se
constituant une vraie expérience
professionnelle pour cela et pour
atteindre l'un ou l'autre de ces deux
objectifs soit la pérennisation soit la
qualification l'emploi d'avenir ne tombe
pas dans le travers de vouloir
reproduire ce qui a marché la situation
a beaucoup changé
les jeunes de 2012 ne sont pas ceux de
1997 le marché de l'emploi n'est plus
structuré de la même manière avec
l'explosion des temps partiels et
l'apparition de nouveaux emplois emplois
technologiques en pro liés à la gestion
du développement durable emploi de la
société de services c'est pourquoi
j'apprécie que l'emploi d'avenir et été
élaborée comme un dispositif adapté
ajusté de la manière la plus adéquate
pour l'employeur et l'employé en prenant
par exemple la capacité et le besoin
d'un tutorat en plus au plus près des
distorsions française ce texte a aussi
privilégié une approche territoriale qui
nous est chère au sénat avec une
priorité donnée aux jeunes des zones
urbaines sensibles des zones de
revitalisation virale et de l'outre-mer
remarquons qu'il s'agit d'un hommage à
caractère prioritaire mais non exclusif
pour les jeunes ciblage du public
ciblage géographique accompagnement des
jeunes bénéficiaires avec suivi social
personnalisé obligations ou faculté d'un
tutorat sélection des structures
titulaire de l'aide et des organismes de
suivi reconnaissance des connaissances
et de l'expérience acquise
ce dispositif est prêt si complet
structurants et a fait l'objet d'un
examen de financement initial hors ne
tardons pas je me réjouis que la date
d'entrée en vigueur des emplois d'avenir
était avancée au 1er novembre 2012 notre
jeunesse ne peut plus attendre mais de
grâce qu'on ne me dise pas que les
dépenses envers la jeunesse constitue
uniquement un coot vous avez eu raison
monsieur le ministre de préciser nous
affirmons contraire qu'elle constitue un
bel investissement sur l'avenir
oui nous sommes soumis à l'urgence d'une
situation dont nous venons d'hériter
réparer ce qui a été détruit
reconstruire la cohésion sociale et cela
passe par la lutte contre le chômage
aujourd'hui est enfin venu le temps de
la mobilisation
car s'il est un domaine où le mot
urgence s'impose c'est bien la matière
d'emploi et de lutte contre le chômage
c'est là la bataille prioritaire avec
d'un côté la nécessité de prendre des
mesures d'urgence comme nous le faisons
aujourd'hui avec des emplois d'avenir et
bientôt avec le contrat de génération et
de l'autre côté des mesures plus
structurelles par l'engagement de
réformes de fond de relance de l'emploi
bref aujourd'hui et j'en termine là
madame la présidente
il s'agissait notamment d'envoyer un
signal à la jeunesse pour lui dire
qu'elle a un avenir et que cet avenir
est dans l'emploi je vous remercie
merci chers collègues
la parole est à dominique watrin
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues comme ma
collègue isabelle pasquet je considère
que face à la situation dramatique que
subissent les jeunes de notre pays il
fallait effectivement que le
gouvernement agissent promptement le
projet de loi qui nous est soumis
aujourd'hui tels que d'ailleurs modifié
par l'assemblée puis par notre
commission nous parait être améliorée
par rapport à sa version initiale le
volet formation a été renforcée
cependant les nouvelles dispositions non
pas selon nous encore suffisamment de
force contraignante pour les employeurs
c'est à dire qu'elle ne garantissent pas
encore suffisamment leur pleine
application
cela résulte sans doute du fait que les
engagements la matière comme ce qui est
de la pérennisation des contrats figure
exclusivement sur la demande d' aide
comme si l'engagement la structure
d'accueil ne valait que pour l'état au
motif que celui ci finance sans doute
aurait-il été souhaitable monsieur le
ministre pour que ces droits soient
pleinement imposables aux bénéficiaires
des emplois d'avenir que les engagements
de l'employeur figure à la fois sur la
demande l'aide ce qui est légitime mais
également sur le contrat de travail qui
lie l'employeur au salarié ainsi recruté
ce dernier ne pouvant en cas de
contestation que se prévaloir
effectivement de son contrat de travail
cela est d'autant plus important qu'en
raison de la dématérialisation de la
procédure de demande dead
il semblerait que contrairement aux
anciens c'est hui les bénéficiaires des
emplois d'avenir ne soient pas appelés à
signer cette demande d'être aussi
serait-il utile que les décrets
d'application prévoit les modalités
d'information des jeunes recrutés quant
à l'existence de leurs droits par
exemple en prévoyant lors de la
signature du contrat un livret
d'information
je profite d'ailleurs de l'occasion qui
m'est fait d'intervenir sur cette
question de l'information pour
interroger monsieur le ministre et le
rapporteur sur les conséquences d'un
amendement de notre rapporteur adoptés
en commission des affaires sociales et
qui a su prix
mais l'obligation d'information des
institutions représentatives du
personnel sur un sujet pourtant
fondamentale l'exécution de ces contrats
notamment quant aux obligations de
formation
d'après ce que j'ai compris il
semblerait que cet amendement de
suppression ne soit que formelle dans la
mesure où le code du travail prévoit
déjà une disposition similaire
or il me semble que cette réponse n'est
que partielle et je crains que l'état
actuel du droit ne correspondent pas
tout à fait aux dispositions que
prévoyait la linea supprimés en effet
l'article 23 23 48 du code du travail
prévoit effectivement une information
des comités d'entreprise le cas échéant
des délégués du personnel sur je cite la
conclusion des conventions ouvrant droit
des contrats initiative emploi il ya des
contrats d'accompagnement dans l'emploi
or le projet de loi prévoyait que
l'information porte également sur
l'exigent l'exécution des obligations de
formation ce qui n'est pas le cas dans
l'article l 23 23 48 du code de travail
ce volet formation constitue pourtant
une priorité pour notre groupe est une
véritable chance pour les bénéficiaires
c'est pourquoi nous considérons que
l'information des institutions
représentatives du personnel sur l'état
d'avancement des actions formation mise
en oeuvre est encore légitime enfin
monsieur le ministre je voudrais vous
poser une dernière question relative à
l'intégration des emplois d'avenir dans
l'effectif de la structure d'accueil
à l'heure actuelle ils en sont exclues
comme l'ensemble des ses huits
d'ailleurs or en octobre dernier le
tribunal d'instance de marseille a rendu
une décision contraire au projet de loi
puisque le tribunal considère je cite
que les salariés en contrat aidé
devraient être comptabilisés dans les
effectifs des entreprises ce qui leur
donne accès au droit fondamental en
représentation syndicale et une
représentation du personnel
le tribunal d'instance considérant que
l'article 11 11 3 du code du travail qui
exclut ses salariés en contrats aidés
des effectifs était contraire au droit
européen et plus précisément à la
directive du 11 mars 2002 et quatre
établissements un cadre général relatif
à l'information et la consultation du
travailleur et expliquant qu'une telle
disposition prive je cite l'arrêt de
salariés titulaires d'un contrat aidé du
droit de bénéficier d'institutions
représentatives du personnel
cela n'est pas conforme selon ce
tribunal au droit communautaire qui
détermine une protection minimale à
laquelle les états ne peuvent déroger
qu'en adoptant des mesures nationales
plus favorable aux travailleurs fin de
citation au regard de cette décision et
de sa portée concrète pour les salariés
ne pensez vous pas monsieur ministre
qu'il serait souhaitable de revenir sur
cette situation
merci chers collègues la parole est à
colette giudicelli
merci madame la présidente monsieur
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
nous sommes tous d'accord pour dire que
la situation du chômage des jeunes est
bien sûr très préoccupant cent vingt
mille d'entre eux sortent chaque année
du système scolaire sans diplôme
quarante mille jeunes parents décident
d'interrompre leurs études sans un
niveau de qualification reconnue
bien évidemment nous souhaitons tous
aussi trouver des solutions pour notre
jeunesse dont l'insertion
professionnelle est évidemment de plus
en plus difficile cependant nous
divergeons monsieur le ministre la
méthode et le moyen d'y parvenir
la recette de l'emploi et des n'est
sûrement pas la bonne solution pour les
jeunes sans formation
la liste est très longue des dispositifs
qui ont échoué ou qui n'ont pas vraiment
permis d'insérer ce gène dans l'emploi
je me souviens et chacun d'entre nous se
souvient depuis 1984 nous avons eu les
tubes les crs les cec les cae
les cio a eu les c hui les civils et
j'en ai certainement oublié aujourd'hui
vous nous proposez les emplois d'avenir
de ces emplois aidés qui ont été fort
coûteux n'ont jamais vraiment réussi à
répondre au problème du chômage des
jeunes sans qualification
parce que procurait une occupation des
jeunes pendant quelques années je crois
ne suffit pas il faut leur donner une
vraie formation qui leur permettent
d'aller sur le marché de l'emploi pour
trouver un vrai travail dans tous les
cas c'est le développement de
l'apprentissage qui devraient être notre
priorité nationale
plus de deux tiers d'entre eux
décrochent un emploi à l'issue de leur
contrat d'apprentissage et on est proche
de 90 % au bout de trois ans un exemple
l'allemagne compte 1,6 million
d'apprentis
en france nous en avons 425 mines au
cours de ces dernières années les
différents gouvernements ont favorisé
cette logique des formations par
alternance au titre desquels figurent
justement les contrats d'apprentissage
mais aussi les contrats de
professionnalisation et je reconnais
volontiers que le volet formation de ce
contrat d'avenir a été amélioré par nos
collègues de l'assemblée nationale mais
j'ai quand même quelques interrogations
concernant ce dispositif dans un
contexte budgétaire extrêmement
préoccupant est il raisonnable ce ni-ni
se mobilisent et puis de 1,8 milliard
d'euros par an en effet le cours
présentera un milliard et demi d'euros
pour l'état 75% du smic est un minimum
on peut calculer de 300 à 400 millions
que vous avez mobilisé que vous avez
demandé aux associations et aux
collectivités
pouvez-vous d'ailleurs à ce propos
monsieur le ministre nous donner des
précisions sur le coût précis et globale
de ce dispositif
ma seconde interrogation porte sur la
fin de contrat
que va-t-il se passer au bout de trois
ans que vont-ils devenir on nous donne
souvent l'exemple du succès de l'ancien
dispositif des emplois jeunes soixante
pour cent de ceux qui avaient un emploi
sont restés chez leur employeur à
l'issue du contrat mais on oublie de
dire c'est un mauvais exemple parce
qu'il faut pas oublier justement que 40
% des bénéficiaires étaient des jeunes
diplômés d'enseignement supérieur du
côté employeur une fois encore la charge
de ces contrats pèsera sur les
collectivités et les associations
générant pour elle des frais de
personnel supplémentaire
je ne vois vraiment pas comment les
associations les collectivités
territoriales pourront financièrement
pérenniser ses emplois issus des
contrats de trois ans et un vrai travail
ne serait être exclusivement un emploi
public
enfin pour terminer ma troisième
interrogation par sur la discrimination
territoriale peut vous souhaiter mettre
en place cet article dans une importance
essentielle au territoire
vous avez décidé de donner la priorité
aux jeunes résidant dans certains
d'entre eux l'extension du dispositif
aux zones de revitalisation rurale ne
réglera pas tout vous allez décider
monsieur le ministre créer cent
cinquante mille emplois d'avenir alors
que l'acide du dispositif comprend
potentiellement 470 mille jeunes peu ou
pas qualifiés ce sont ces territoires
prioritaires qui vont consommer la quasi
totalité des moyens certes le jeune des
quartiers je suis bien d'accord avec
vous les jeunes des quartiers sensibles
doivent être accompagnés c'est la
situation sociale des jeunes concernés
qui doit être l'unique critère je ne
comprendront pas que l'ensemble des
jeunes français en situation de
précarité ne puissent pas accéder à ce
dispositif et que vous fixé comme
priorité ceux qui vivent dans les zones
défavorisées
pour l'ensemble de ces raisons monsieur
le ministre malheureusement je ne
voterai pas ce projet de loi
merci chers collègues
la parole est à sophie primas merci
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre cher collègue m'a prise de
parole ira dans le sens de celui de ma
collègue précédente
pour vous dire qu'évidemment l'insertion
professionnelle des jeunes peu qualifiés
est devenu bien difficile dans une crise
économique qui touche notre pays mais
qui les touchent en priorité et que la
situation de ces jeunes que nous
connaissons tous qui comme on dit dans
mon ma banlieue parisienne tiennent les
murs temps l'activité est importante est
particulièrement préoccupante
l'objectif fixé par votre gouvernement
pour l'insertion de ces jeunes sans
qualification est donc louable et
rassemble nous l'avons dit tous les
bancs de notre hémicycle en ce sens
d'ailleurs je voudrais rappeler que le
choix du précédent gouvernement avait
été de conduire une politique sans
précédent en faveur de l'apprentissage
et de la formation en alternance
véritable voie de sucre
c'est pour l'insertion pérenne de ses
jeunes les investissements d'avenir pour
le développement et l'extension des
établissements la promotion de
l'apprentissage vont porter leurs fruits
dans toutes ces années qui viennent il
aurait d'ailleurs fallu continuer ses
efforts en allégeant particulier les
contraintes administratives souvent trop
lourde pour les entreprises si ce qui
est proposé aujourd'hui va dans le sens
de la bataille que tout gouvernement
doit mener contre ce fléau qu'est
l'éloignement des jeunes de l'activité
professionnelle ce dispositif est en
décalage avec la réalité de l'emploi en
france ces emplois dits d'avenir
annoncé un peu en urgence manifestement
pour répondre à l'inquiétude
grandissante des français sont bien sûr
à suffisant vous l'avez dit vous-même
tout à l'heure et je crains que les
contrats de génération que vous nous
avez annoncé monsieur le ministre en
complément ne suffisent pas je regrette
que le budget conséquent engager pour
ces emplois conduisent à ne créer
majoritairement que des contrats
temporaires dans un cadre restreint les
empêchant la plupart du temps de
déboucher sur des emplois pérennes
il s'agira principalement d'emplois
créés dans le secteur public ou
associatif secteur tous deux soumis à
une politique de réduction des dépenses
publiques et donc plusieurs études ici
même au sénat ont montré qu'ils ne
permettaient pas un taux d'insertion
comparable à celui existant dans le
secteur privé
certes le secteur public et le secteur
associatif peuvent être un vivier pour
trois ans mais in fine et l'objectif
primordial doit être de pérenniser des
emplois créés et non pas de précariser à
retardement dans les conditions
économiques actuelles nous aurions
préféré que vous puissiez proposé avant
tout ces contrats aux entreprises
notamment aux tpe et aux pme
quitte à prioriser en accord avec les
organisations professionnelles les
secteurs d'activité en tension dans
lesquels l'éloignement des jeunes au
travail peut être plus facilement comblé
plus grave pour moi monsieur le ministre
est que ce dispositif me semble
inéquitable inéquitable inexplicable
comment expliquer monsieur le ministre
aux jeunes en grande difficulté de ma
vallée de seine industriels qu'ils
n'auraient pas la chance
quel paradoxe d'habiter dans les
quartiers sensibles et pour qu'il soit
écarté de ce dispositif
it if pourquoi rajouter pourquoi
rajouter l'injustice sociale à une
injustice territoriales
merci monsieur le ministre
en effet ce dispositif en son article
1er je lis le texte monsieur le ministre
vise explicitement en priorité les
jeunes résidant en zus en zone de
revitalisation ou en outre mer
par conséquent les jeunes issus de
bassin d'emploi en très grande
difficulté ou éloignées gravement de
l'emploi mais ne résidant pas sur le bon
territoire seront non prioritaires donc
probablement exclu
ce n'est pas acceptable le dispositif
doit concerner chaque jeune en
difficulté ce n'est non le territoire
mais la personne qu'il faut viser notre
groupe demande donc la suppression de
cet article pour ces deux raisons
majeures et à défaut de cette
suppression
nous proposerons des amendements pour
tenter de rétablir en particulier
l'égalité de traitement de tous les
jeunes principes essentiels de notre
constitution et auxquels je suis
certaine monsieur le ministre vous serez
sensible attentif et ouvert je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
gisèle printz messieurs les ministres
mesdames la président des chers
collègues tout au long de sa campagne
présidentielle françois hollande a fait
de la jeunesse la grande cause de son
quinquennat la création de 150 mille
emplois d'avenir et bien un engagement
fort du programme présidentiel destiné
aux jeunes en particulier issus des
quartiers sensibles
ils ont en effet un besoin urgent d'une
première expérience professionnelle sur
une durée longue
moi qui suis élu d'un territoire
industriel la moselle particulièrement
frappés par la crise économique et
sociale
je peux vous dire qu'à tel dispositif
est particulièrement attendu est urgent
avec eux ces générations ne désespère
pas de la république
mon intervention portera sur deux points
l'intérêt du dispositif en ayant bien
présent à l'esprit l'expérience positive
des emplois jeunes de la période 1997
et le rôle que peuvent jouer les
établissements publics de coopération
intercommunale dans la mise en oeuvre
pratique des emplois d'avenir
en plus de la formation l'expérience
professionnelle acquise dans la durée
favorise l'accès des jeunes à l'emploi à
l'issue du programme
nous devons particulièrement veillé à
offrir autant de possibilités d'emploi
pour les filles que pour les garçons et
appliquer les règles de l'égalité
salariale entre hommes et femmes il faut
mettre à terme avait faux procès souvent
entendu sur les bancs de l'opposition ni
pardon ni en la création d'emplois lors
de la mise en place dix emplois jeunes
en 2006 selon les statistiques établies
par la direction de l'animation de la
recherche des études et des statistiques
un organisme dépendant du ministère de
l'emploi confirment que les emplois
jeunes avaient permis la création de
trois cent dix mille postes entre 1997
et 2002 de plus trois quarts des
bénéficiaires ont occupé un poste
immédiatement après leur sortie de ce
dispositif
cette mise au point qui me tenait à
coeur est en fait je voulais attirer
l'attention du gouvernement sur le rôle
que pourrait jouer dans la mise en
oeuvre des emplois d'avenir
les établissements publics de
coopération intercommunale
ils sont bien entendu éligible en tant
qu'employeur comme le prévoit le projet
de loi à l'article l 51,34 son os 2 du
code du travail qui vise les
collectivités territoriales et leurs
groupements les opci dont une des
missions prioritaires et le
développement économique et
l'aménagement du territoire peuvent donc
être au coeur du dispositif
en outre les communautés d'agglomération
ont parmi les blocs de compétences
obligatoires prévues par la loi
la faculté de choisir la politique de la
ville
j'ajoute que la réforme territoriale du
16 décembre 2010 a prévu l'obligation
pour les opci
d'établir schéma de mutualisation des
services entre la communauté et les
communes adhérentes
la mise en oeuvre du dispositif pourrait
dans un certain nombre de cas et
notamment pour des communautés de
communes recomptant de petites communes
est un élément de ces schémas en cours
d'élaboration
monsieur le ministre en liaison avec
votre collègue en charge des
collectivités territoriales pourquoi ne
pas engager une concertation à ce sujet
avec les associations d'élus notamment
l'association des maires de france et
l'assemblée des communautés de france
afin d'encourager le recours au
dispositif
nous savons bien nous sénatrices et
sénateurs
quelles peuvent être les difficultés
concrètes des petites communes quelles
que soient leurs bonnes volontés elle
qui disposent de moyens humains et
budgétaires insuffisant notamment dans
l'encadrement ou encore pour la gestion
des ressources humaines
je pense qu'il est de notre rôle au sein
de la haute assemblée issue des
collectivités territoriales de nous
faire le relais de ses aspects pratiques
rencontrées sur le terrain
dans le souci de la réussite d'un enjeu
majeur qui est celui de l'emploi des
jeunes dans leur insertion dans notre
société
merci chers collègues
la parole est au président didier
guillaume madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues les
emplois d'avenir monsieur le ministre
sont un dispositif indispensable pour
remettre les jeunes sur le chemin de
l'emploi et par conséquent sur le chemin
de la république parce que c'est bien de
cela dont il s'agit
remettre les jeunes dans notre pacte
républicain
sur le chemin de la république et c'est
la raison pour laquelle j interviens sur
cet article du projet de loi qui est le
coeur du texte car je soutiens avec
enthousiasme ce projet de loi oui mes
chers collègues
ce texte est une avancée majeure sur le
front de l'emploi des jeunes
son objectif est bien de remettre des
dizaines de milliers de jeunes sur les
rails de l'emploi et au delà même sur le
chemin de la république
vous l'avez toutes et tous dit la
discussion générale les chiffres sont
éloquents
plus d'un jeune sur deux dandys sans
diplôme ne travaille pas ces jeunes sont
sans horizon en dehors de la société
beaucoup se sentent marginalisés ils ont
le sentiment d'être laissés de côté par
ceux là mêmes dont ils ont le sentiment
que ne s'occupe que deux ces jeunes là
sont ceux qui doutent de leur avenir
comme de leur présent la société ne doit
pas les oublier je soutiens ce texte car
il permettra à ces jeunes de retrouver
le chemin de la société il ne suffit pas
de dire que la république ne laisse
aucun de ses enfants sur le côté de la
route
la république doit aussi trouver les
moyens de créer une harmonie entre les
générations et ce texte et contribuer et
je ne parle pas seulement de
perspectives professionnelles
en effet comment rêver à une vie
meilleure quand on est inactif comment
acquérir la maturité devenir un adulte
sans cette première étape de l'emploi de
l'autonomie financière et donc de
l'autonomie par rapport aux parents en
réalité la problématique que nous
abordons ne concerne pas seulement les
jeunes
elle nous concerne tous elle concerne
les familles elles concernent la société
car le chômage des jeunes est une menace
très sérieuse
pour la cohésion de notre république
pour l'harmonie de notre nation aussi
devons-nous répondre à cette question
quelle est la place que nous voulons
accorder aux jeunes dans une société
marquée par la gravité d'une crise
économique
cette crise terrible qui écrase tout sur
son passage
même les plus forts souffre la finance
les entreprises d etat
alors les jeunes et surtout les jeunes
sans diplôme sans formation se sentent
mis de fête au ban de la société
ces emplois d'avenir monsieur le
ministre sont un outil nécessaire pour
lutter contre ce fléau qu'est le chômage
des jeunes
le président de la république ça a été
déjà dit aussi a fait de la jeunesse
l'un des thèmes fondateurs de son action
le contrat de génération qui sera mis en
place dans les semaines qui viennent
avec les entreprises comme ces emplois
d'avenir sont au coeur des dispositifs
destinés à améliorer la situation des
jeunes plus de 700 mille jeunes sont
sans emploi sans formation en
privilégiant cette mesure dans cette
mesure le contrat à durée indéterminée
ou le contrat à durée déterminée de 36
mois
les emplois d'avenir réinsère
durablement les jeunes dans le monde du
travail dans ce projet de loi l'accent
est mis sur la formation
tout est mis en oeuvre pour favoriser
l'acquisition d'une formation elle est
essentielle et la convention passée
entre l'employeur et le jeune est un
gage de sérieux
alors j'entends les critiques visant le
coût de cette mesure
500 millions d'euros en 2013 un milliard
et demi par an dès que les cent
cinquante mille emplois seront pourvus
mais à titre comparatif
je voudrais simplement dire que le
bouclier fiscal a représenté un manque à
gagner de deux milliards 5,2 euros entre
2007 et 2011 et a mis beaucoup de jeunes
au chômage
j'entends les critiques sur des emplois
gadgets des emplois publics au rabais
attention mes chers collègues au
dénigrement
attention au fait de considérer qu'il ya
des degrés dans la qualité des emplois
non tout jeunes reprenant une activité
où tout jeune acquérant un premier
emploi
futile en emplois d'avenir est un jeune
qui réussit cet emploi est une première
victoire pour combattre le chômage
nous faisons le choix d'investir soit
jeunesse parce que nous croyons ses
talents et que toutes les solutions sata
expérimenté pour les faire émarger
émerger mais la france est diverse les
territoires sont divers et la jeunesse
est la même et je veux avoir une pensée
pour les jeunes qui vivent dans les
zones rurales mes chers collègues
ces derniers n'habite pas dans les zones
urbaines sensibles mais vivent dans des
zones rurales sensibles en termes de
perspectives d'emploi ce sont les mêmes
bien souvent loin des services publics
loin de l'accès haut débit il se sent
touché par la double peine
et merci monsieur le ministre de faire
en sorte que cette loi comme c'est écrit
dans votre projet s'adresse aussi bien
aux jeunes des zones urbaines sensibles
qu'aux jeunes de la ruralité
il est important que cette france
diverse que cela répond c'est cette
france diverse soit pour tous les jeunes
qu'ils habitent en ville où qu'ils
habitent en zone rurale c'est
indispensable
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
on entendra des critiques certains sur
les bancs de l'opposition vont voter le
texte donne peut-être ne le voterons pas
alors à ceux qui ne veulent pas voter
pour les emplois d'avenir
je leur demande de voter contre le
chômage et aux membres de la majorité
qui va voter pour les emplois d'avenir
ils auront fait un pas important pour
remettre le moral pour remettre le pied
à l'étrier à la france des jeunes qui se
sent délaissée merci merci chers
collègues est la parole est à serge
larcher
oui madame la présidente monsieur des
ministres messieurs les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues j'ai beaucoup entendu de
critiques au sujet du projet de loi
relatifs aux emplois d'avenir que nous
évoquons aujourd'hui tout texte est
critiquable et celui ci comporte
évidemment des aspects qui peuvent être
améliorées pour le cas d'espèce ce qui
me gène le discours de certains c'est le
caractère strictement idéologique de
leur opposition
si je les entends bien l'emploi d'avenir
ne serait pas acceptable parce que le
rôle de l'état n'est pas subventionner
l'emploi
si je les entends encore l'état n'aurait
pas les moyens
si je l'étais temps enfin ces emplois
irait à l'encontre d'un nécessaire
mouvement de réduction des effectifs des
collectivités publiques
je souhaite ici analysé très sereinement
ces trois arguments sur le premier point
au sujet du rôle de l'état en matière de
financement de ces endroits je considère
qu'il s'agit d'une nécessité serbe dans
un monde parfait la création de la
création d'emplois n'a pas besoin d'être
3g possède simplement de la rencontre de
besoin et d'une offre à l'occurrence ne
sommes pas dans un monde parfait et nous
sommes dans un monde en crise oui en
crise grave dans grease quand près de
cinq cent mille jeunes sont sans emploi
et sans formation il est plus il n'est
plus temps de se demander si l'état doit
agir
il doit agir et il est temps d'agir
je le dis avec d'autant plus de
conviction que la situation est encore
plus dramatique dans les régions
d'outre-mer où la plus haut plus la
moitié de jeunes sont au chômage
et parmi ces que eu 41 % sont sans
aucune forme qualification dans une
telle période
l'intervention de l'état en faveur de
l'emploi n'est donc pas seulement une
option
elle possède une nécessité voire d'une
obligation
sur ce bon point au sujet du coût du
dispositif
ce débat n'est pas tout si logique
d'état toute logique strictement
budgétaire en fait la véritable question
est quel coup du défaut de formation et
de l'inactivité chronique d'une partie
de la jeunesse
et je ne parle pas seulement du coût
économique de prise en charge de
l'exclusion je parle du coût social et
sociétal un pays peut-il durablement
espérer se développer en laissant sur le
bord de la route
une partie de ce qu'il devrait justement
construire son avenir
le coût de l'inactivité c'est parfois la
désespérance la drogue la violence et
c'est une charge au combien plus lourd
pour nos sociétés que les moyens comme
mobilisera l'état poussé emplois
d'avenir
pour finir j'aimerais évoquer
l'apparenté contradiction entre la mise
en place de tels dispositifs dans une
période où il y aurait nécessité de
réduire les effectifs des collectivités
publiques
l'argument est intéressant mais ceux qui
en usent feint d'ignorer que cette même
période et celle d'être du papy boom où
le rythme dès le départ à la retraite
est élevé pour ma part je vois dans les
emplois d'avenir une opportunité pour
former ce qui demain peuvent occuper une
partie des emplois qui se libèrent pour
les collectivités territoriales
l'intérêt du dispositif est de pouvoir
former progressivement selon une logique
de gestion prévisionnelle des emplois et
des compétences
les futurs professionnels du service
public il ne s'agit pas simplement de
créer un effet d'aubaine et d'occuper
des jeunes pendu à 3 ans puis de s'en
débarrasser il s'agit véritablement de
les préparer à prendre efficacement leur
place dans notre société
pour toutes ces raisons que je viens
d'évoquer il me semble donc chers
collègues que l'ogec de jeu dangereux
est bel est bien d'améliorer le
dispositif qui est une chance pour inès
et notamment pour nos outre vert et
c'est pour toutes ces raisons dans l'eau
voter ce texte
merci chers collègues la parole est à
hervé maurey merci madame la présidente
monsieur les miss mener mes chers
collègues quelques mots concernant cet
article 1er tout d'abord sur sur la
forme
j'observe que nous avons à nouveau un
texte selon la procédure accélérée
j'en suis d'autant plus étonné que le
ministre sappin avait évoqué à
l'assemblée nationale le sait que ce
texte n'était pas urgent je le cite il y
avait dit il n'y a pas d'urgence
immédiate
à propos de ces emplois en dix ans leur
élaboration demandera du temps
nous discuterons notamment des crédits
alors consacré en du débat budgétaire et
j'observe aussi qu'au cours de cette
session extraordinaire nous avons deux
textes tous les deux sous forme de
procédure accélérée
je me demande si c'est ça l'amélioration
des conditions de travail du parlement
qui nous avait été promise par la
majorité et par le gouvernement et j'ai
vraiment le sentiment en ayant ces deux
textes dans l'urgence que l'on est passé
de la léthargie de juillet à
l'emballement de septembre j'aurais
également regretté que ce texte comme
celui sur le logement aborde la prob la
problématique de manière séquencée on
n'arrive pas avec ce gouvernement avoir
des textes qui abordent globalement les
choses c'était vrai sur le logement nous
a parlé que de logement social c'est
vrai avec ce texte on n'aborde que la
question du traitement social du chômage
chez les jeunes alors sur sur le fond
bien sûr il faut se préoccuper du
chômage bien sûr c'est une priorité
bien sûr nous avons trois millions de
chômeurs bien sûr la question de
l'emploi des jeunes est encore plus
préoccupante puisque nous avons quatre
cent soixante dix mille jeunes sans
emploi que l'augmentation du chômage des
jeunes a augmenté très fortement en un
ans il a augmenté de 7%
et c'est donc très bien que le
gouvernement s'attaque à cette
problématique
le problème c'est que
je trouve que ce qui nous est proposé
n'est pas à la hauteur de la situation
parce que face à ce drame qui est celui
de l'emploi des jeunes qu'est ce que
nous propose le gouvernement
il nous propose finalement de réinventer
les emplois jeunes de 1997 mais mais
mais en moins bien en moins bien
il laissait emploi sont moins nombreux
cent cinquante mille au lieu de 800
milles ils seront moins aidé puisque
l'état ne prendra en charge que 75% à
80%
ils seront sur une durée plus courte qui
sera de 3 ans et pas de cinq ans et en
plus il ne concerneront que certains
territoires et le pire le pire c'est que
le gouvernement ne semble pas se rendre
compte qu'en fait la situation a
fondamentalement changé en quinze ans
parce que les emplois jeunes ont été un
relatif succès dans la mesure où
effectivement 60% des emplois jeunes ont
été pérennisés
mais la situation a fondamentalement
changé parce que aujourd'hui la
différence fondamentale avec la
situation d'il ya quinze ans c'est que
les collectivités locales ne sont
absolument pas en situation de
pérenniser ses emplois
on sait très bien que demain les
collectivités locales qui ont des
dotations qui stagne qui ont des des
emplois dont le nombre devrait être
limitée ne pourront pas pérenniser ses
emplois et donc on promet à ces jeunes
un emploi parking et c'est d'autant plus
préoccupant et nous y reviendrons au
cours des amendements présentés par
notre groupe qu'il n'y a même pas de
réelles garanties sur la formation des
jeunes dans le cadre de ces emplois je
comprends que vous soyez gênée mes chers
collègues may et la courtoisie
ayez la courtoisie de me laisser parler
madame la présidente vous avez la parole
merci beaucoup à la présidente je
comprends que mes propos dérange mais
notre assemblée est habituellement plus
courtoise que ce soir il est donc tout à
fait regrettable que ces emplois soient
essentiellement tournée vers le secteur
public et pas davantage vers le secteur
marchand qui n'est concerné qu'à la
marge
et là aussi nous aurons des amendements
en ce sens et il est tout à fait
incompréhensible que dans le cadre
d'emplois qui révèrent le secteur
marchand servir les entreprises
les aides ne soient pas de 75% mais de
30 à 35%
ce qui montre là encore une méfiance
vis-à-vis des entreprises
alors la question de l'emploi des jeunes
c'est quoi aujourd'hui c'est à la fois
un problème de formation un problème
d'inadéquation entre l'offre et la
demande
et malheureusement ce texte n'y répond
pas et c'est aussi un problème de coût
du travail et sur la question du travail
on se réjouit que le président de la
république et découvert qu'il y ait un
problème de compétitivité dans notre
entreprise dans notre pays pardon mais
on aimerait voir enfin des actes et des
propositions concrètes
parce que pour le moment on est dans la
découverte du problème de la
compétitivité
mais les actes ne sont pas en conformité
que cette découverte puisque les seuls
actes qui ont été pris par le
gouvernement c'est pour aggraver les
charges des entreprises avec la
suppression de la tva anti
délocalisation avec la suppression de
l'exonération de charges sociales soit
heures supplémentaires et avec les les
nouvelles impositions qui sont prévus
dans le cadre de la loi de finances
seraient entreprises
donc j'adore vraiment de la part du
gouvernement et de la majorité que l'on
aborde ce problème au fond et de manière
structurelle si chers collègues
la parole est à la mairie merci madame
la présidente je dois dire que j'ai
écouté beaucoup d'attention et je dirais
avec beaucoup de courage plus que
viennent nous dire notre collègue mort
et parce qu'il ya quand même un tissu de
contradictions qui est peu banale vous
comparez les contrats d'avenir avec les
contrats jeunes et bien écoutez si ils
ont le même succès que les contrats
jeunes
ça va être une réussite puisque vous
avez vous-même que 70% ont été
pérennisés que deuxièmement vous ne
dites mais vous pourrez pas dans les
collectivités financent et écoutez je
voudrais pas être désagréable avec vous
mais permettez moi quand même de vous
rappeler que vous êtes quand même
responsable de l'étranglement des
collectivités locales et en particulier
de la perte d'autonomie financière des
collectivités locales
c'est quand même pas nous qui avons
supprimé la taxe professionnelle
et puis je crois que dans ce domaine là
il faut rappeler que avec les
emplois-jeunes effectivement on avait
rempli d'espoir non seulement aux jeunes
mais aux parents et même rap hareng et
et monsieur mort et je voudrais pas être
cru avec vous en ce début de soirée
mais quand vous osez critiquer les
mesures qui sont proposées aujourd'hui
je voudrais vous faire un petit rappel
historique et vous renvoyer à quelques
années en arrière mais où vous étiez aux
responsabilités est ce que vous pourriez
nous parler du cpe s'il vous plaît parce
que si vous nous parliez du cpe
effectivement vous avez eu un véritable
succès jamais il ya eu autant de
personnes dans la rue que grâce au cpe
et si au début c'étaient les jeunes les
parents et les grands parents avaient
bien compris la supercherie et je suis
mesuré dans mes propos quand je parle de
supercherie et que monsieur mort et
quand on est face à un tel bilan et
fasse un tel catastrophisme de la
situation vous avez laissé je crois que
faites nous confiance pour redresser la
situation
mais vous savez qu'il nous faudra
beaucoup de courage beaucoup d'audace
pour le faire parce que car même ce que
vous nous laissez c'est un héritage dans
à votre place je n'oserais pas parler
merci chers collègues
jacky le menn vous avez la parole
merci même le président je crois c ces
contrats d'avenir c est vous l'avez tous
bien compris la rencontre d'un besoin
avait le sida en comble un besoin avec
une volonté le besoin pense pas que qui
que ce soit dans cette assemblée le
remettent en cause tout le monde a
constaté et la volonté c'est pour le
gouvernement pas rester les bras
ballants face à cet immense drame que
représente la le fait que nos jeunes
concitoyens sont sans travail et en plus
en désespérance sur l'ensemble du
territoire compte tenu du fait que pour
le départ ou pas sans diplôme
on peut pas nécessairement trouver un
travail en plus d'autres éléments et
semant le péjoratif alors j'ai entendu
dans les interventions
un amoncellement de contre vérités ou de
questions sur lequel le ministre a déjà
répondu cet après midi dans le cadre de
dans le cadre de la discussion générale
alors il a très bien répondu en ce qui
concerne la question du du financement
il est question du financement pendant
trois ans les contrats à durée
indéterminée peuvent aller au delà de
trois ans je pense que les choses sont
claires et là à entendre certains de nos
collègues de la minorité
on a l'impression que bout de trois ans
tout va s'arrêter non c'est pas le cas
derrière l'ensemble du système de
formation dont notre ministre monsieur
repentin nous a très longuement
expliciter les différents éléments cet
après midi fait que avec un tutorat qui
sera en accompagnement et qui est un
point fort sur lequel il faut insister
qui a fait ses preuves dans le passé et
encore ici ou là dans l'hexagone avec le
tutorat
on a là une possibilité de redonner le
punch aux jeunes qui ont pour des
raisons parfois sociale parfois à relier
le système d'éducation mais c'est un
autre dossier un système scolaire c'est
un autre dossier sur lequel se penche le
gouvernement il y a une possibilité de
faire en sorte que ces personnes là ces
jeunes là aille vers un véritable emploi
à hiver un véritable emploi autre
contrevérité on a l'impression que c'est
uniquement dans certains territoires non
c'est sur l'ensemble du territoire c'est
sur l'ensemble de l'hexagone
il y a le fait que sur certaines parties
dans l'hexagone malheureusement et c'est
vrai aussi pour l'outre-mer il y a
malheureusement des priorités compte
tenu du niveau très fort du niveau très
fort de déshérence en matière d'emploi
pour les jeunes sans qualification alors
je crois que c'est ce côté importants et
moi je m'attendrais que l'ensemble de la
représentation nationale ici au niveau
du sénat et au niveau bien sûr la somme
est nationale mais fasse bloc face corps
pour aider nos jeunes en difficulté et
en ayant conscience que c'est un élément
dans un plan d'ensemble qui a été
explicitée par le chef du gouvernement
encore tout à fait récemment il y aura
d'autres mesures notamment les contrats
de génération c'est pas à nous c'est un
élément dans un ensemble mais il ya une
stratégie globale de lutte quant au
chômage et je m'étonne pour le déplorer
que la minorité ne saisissent pas ne
saisissent pas ces opportunités pour
fermement amende honorable par rapport à
ce qui s'est passé jusqu'à l'arrivée de
françois hollande à la présidence de
république
merci merci chers collègues les prises
de parole sur l'article 1er sont
maintenant terminées je passe à la
partie amendements je suis saisi d'un
amendement 68 qui est présenté par
madame pro cassien merci madame la
présidente
cet après midi je n'étais pas en séance
puisque nous avions les états généraux
des collectivités donc j'aimerais bien
que mes collègues ne disent pas monsieur
le ministre a répondu vous messieurs les
ministres ont répandu cet après midi il
y avait des priorités qui sont aussi les
priorités du président du sénat je
voulais dire que jusqu'à présent aucun
d'entre nous au sénat n'avons ni et le
fait que la situation de l'emploi des
jeunes peu ou pas qualifiés étaient
alarmantes
nous aussi nous partageons ce constat et
nous partageons la volonté d'agir mais
nous disons que l'emploi d'avenir tel
que vous le proposez est un acte de
communication puisque les formes dead
d'emplois que vous proposez existe déjà
la formule du contrat aidé a été
éprouvée et prouver de nouveau on soit
par là par vous ou par l'ancienne
majorité
nous pourrions souscrire à cette formule
même si pour nous il s'agit quand même
d'une formule ponctuelles et de faible
ampleur s'ils ne présentaient pas un
certain nombre de défauts que nous
estimons majeur ma collègue chantal
jouanno l'a dénoncé tout à l'heure c'est
après midi l'emploi d'avenir a conduit
quand même un exploit que de créer un
cdd de trois ans ce que la droite
n'aurait jamais osé faire certes on doit
faire des cdi
mais combien de cdi seront proposés on
fera le bilan je pense bien je pense
bien qu'il y aura plus de cdd et surtout
en matière de droit du travail crée des
cdd de trois ans
ça a été réglé dans le texte mais si
quand même assez surprenant alors que
les cdd en droit du travail ne doivent
pas dépasser deux ans donc le respect
des règles du travail me paraît un petit
peu et
nantes au lieu de déboucher sur des
emplois stages stable il s'agira vous
espérez que ça ne sera pas le cas
monsieur le ministre mais sur les
ministres des emplois précaires alors
que nous souhaitons tous ces emplois
débouche sur des emplois pérennes or
pour avoir des emplois pérennes
il faudrait s'orienter vers le secteur
marchand vers l'économie des seuls
secteurs qui crée réellement des
richesses en plus nous reprochons à ce
dispositif de ciblage sur un certain
nombre de zones
les zones dans les zus dans les nerfs
dans l'outre-mer moi je veux simplement
parler des zones urbaines
nous avons fait des grands programmes en
rue nous avons déplacé des populations
comment allons nous dire à certains
jeunes
si vous habitiez encore à 500 mètres de
là vous seriez prioritaires et
maintenant vous ne l'êtes plus comment
les maires ici présents vont devoir
gérer les jeunes qui éventuellement
voudront aller les voir en leur disant
nous habitons de votre commune et nous
souhaitons avoir un emploi d avenir et d
nous et vous leur direz non peut-être si
je n'ai personne d'autre ou si les
emplois prioritaire des personnes qui
sont dans ces zones ne sont pas pourvus
eh bien ce sont les raisons pour
lesquelles notre groupe trouve que ce
processus ait beaucoup améliorable et
nous le ferons que s'il est améliorée
merci chers collègues
l'avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur sur cet amendement 68
l'amendement 68 mes chers collègues
proposé par madame pro cassia et ses
collègues est reportée radical vous
l'avez compris puisqu'il s'agit de
supprimer l'article 1
alors cet amendement repose sur des
attendus qui sont faux en particulier on
semble confondre exclusivité et
priorités je veux les réaffirmer ici
avec force à la suite des propos des
ministres tout à l'heure tous les jeunes
peuvent être bénéficiaires de ce
dispositif des emplois jeunes pour cette
raison essentielle naturellement la
commission apporter un avis défavorable
merci monsieur le rapporteur l'avis du
gouvernement merci monsieur le ministre
bien y at il une demande d'explications
de vote je n'en vois pas je vais donc
mettre aux voix cet article cet
amendement 68 qui a eu un double avis
défavorable qui est pour
merci qui est contre merci abstentions
merci l'amendement n'est pas adopté
l'amendement 4 rectifié bis même procas
tient cet amendement reprend un débat
que nous avons eu une discussion que
nous avons eue avec monsieur le ministre
en commission puisqu'ils nous apparaît
c'est un peu bizarre que ce dispositif
puisse s'adresser aux jeunes de 16 à 18
ans les emplois d'avenir concerne les
publics jeunes prioritaires qui aurait
fait et qui ont des problèmes
d'insertion ou qui auraient subi
plusieurs années de galère à 16 ans à 10
à 17 ans comment peut-on déjà dire qu'on
a subi des années sans formation et
qu'on n'a pas trouvé d'emploi really à
d'autres formes
il y a d'abord l'enseignement parce que
la première des choses serait qu'il ne
quitte pas l'enseignement et la deuxième
chose il ya d'autres formes comme
l'apprentissage
monsieur
le ministre du travail en ce sens
commission m'a bien dit qu'effectivement
à 16 ans n'était pas l'âge opportun mais
qu'il ne voulait pas qu effectivement un
certain nombre de personnes à 17 ans ou
à 17 ans et demi ne puisse pas bénéficié
de ces emplois d'avenir c'est la raison
pour laquelle je vous ai écoutés
monsieur le ministre et que je propose
de remplacer alors je rectifie mon
amendement non pas le sel le l'âge de
spare 16 par 18 mai par 17 ans parce que
de 16 à 17 ans il y a quand même il n'y
a qu'un an ou deux on a peut-être
quitter l'enseignement et il ya
peut-être d'autres voies merci madame
procas tiens je vais demander l'avis de
la commission donc sûr maintenant à un
amendement 4 rectifié terre et qui porte
le chiffre de 16 à 17 ans mais ses
rapporteurs bien il est évidemment
souhaitable mes chers collègues que les
mineurs de 16 à 17 ans nous partageons
tous cette exigence puisse être soit en
alternance soit resté en scolarité
malheureusement le réussit le réalisme
nous conduit à constater qu'un certain
nombre de jeunes ont décroché du système
scolaire ne sont pas dans les systèmes
en alternance ne sont ni en emploi ni en
formation mais sont demandeurs d'emploi
est précisément pour cela l'emploi
d'avenir est tout à fait adapté et doit
lui permettre peut-être le cas échéant
soit d'aller vers un processus
qualifiant de faire un retour vers
l'alternance est en tout cas de trouver
une voie de déboucher par rapport à
cette situation de chômage
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous ne
pouvons pas vous suivre madame pro
cassien a misé favorable de la
commission
merci monsieur rapporteur monsieur
ministre l'avis du gouvernement
oh je viens apporter un
défavorable merci monsieur le ministre
bien y at il eu ou parole il n'y en a
pas je vais donc mettre aux voix
l'amendement 4 rectifié terre qui a reçu
un double avis défavorable de la
commission et du goût
le mans qui est pour merci qui est
contre merci abstentions je n'en vois
pas l'amendement n'est pas adopté voilà
pour la discussion de l'article premier
du projet de loi portant création d
emplois d'avenir
je vous retrouve quant à moi cet après
midi à partir de 16h 30
et bien pour la suite de l'examen de ce
texte bonne journée à tous